A couple years ago I interviewed this cop about something that happened to him when he was still a rookie on the force. He and his partner had gotten called out to this suburban house to do something about this squirrel that was running around the attic of the house. And by the time they were done an hour after that, they had accidentally injured the owner of the house. The squirrel had not only evaded capture, he had run through a fireplace, setting himself on fire and then setting a couch on fire. The house was full of smoke. It was a fiasco.
几年前，我采访过一位警官，聊的是他刚入职时发生的一件事。他和搭档接到报案，前往郊区的一户人家处理一只闯进阁楼的松鼠。一个小时后，当他们收工时，竟然意外伤到了房主。那只松鼠不仅没被抓到，还穿过壁炉，把自己烧着了，顺便点燃了沙发。房子里全是烟，简直是一场闹剧。
And just recently, it occurred to me, why have we never had that guy back on the show? Something else interesting must have happened to him in his years on the force.
最近我突然想到，为什么我们从没请那个人再来节目做客？他在当警察的这些年里，肯定还经历过其他有意思的事。
It is August. I remember it being really hot and thunderstorming. And the sun had just gone down. And the call came over for auto accident, van overturned, possible injuries at scene. So I arrive, there's a lot of people in the street, there are some fire trucks there already, and there's a van on its side. And standing next to the van is a man, late 50s, kind of disheveled. I guess he just rolled around in a van.
那是八月。我记得天气非常热，还打着雷。太阳刚下山，就接到了车祸报警，一辆货车翻了，现场可能有人员受伤。我赶到时，街上聚了很多人，消防车已经到了，货车侧翻在一旁。货车旁边站着一名男子，五十多岁，看起来衣衫不整。我想他大概是在货车里翻滚了一通。
And then standing next to the man at his hip and holding his hand was a chimpanzee. Three feet, four feet tall, dressed in a red sweatshirt and jeans and shoes like a person. And they're standing there and being yelled at by the homeowner whose lawn the van came to rest on. They had knocked over fire hydrants. They had damaged his lawn and some trees. So it was a little bit chaotic scene-- lots of lights, lots of people. And I thought this was going to be pretty good show.
在那个男子身旁，牵着他手的是一只黑猩猩。它有三四英尺高，穿着红色运动衫、牛仔裤和鞋子，像个人一样。他们站在那里，被货车撞进草坪的房主大声斥责。他们撞倒了消防栓，损坏了草坪和几棵树。现场有些混乱——到处是闪烁的灯光和人群。我心想，这可真是一出好戏。
After ascertaining that nobody was injured at the scene, the cop, whose name is [? Sean, ?] goes over to the officer who's taken charge of this situation and listens to him interviewing the driver of the van. It seems that the driver of the van has this business where he dress the chimp up and goes out to birthday parties and Bar Mitzvahs and the chimp performs. And they had been coming home from a gig just like that. The man's driving, the chimp's in the passenger seat, wearing a seat belt, just like a passenger.
在确认现场无人受伤后，那位名叫肖恩（音译）的警官走过去，找到负责处理此事的警官，听他盘问货车司机。原来，这名司机经营着一项业务：给黑猩猩穿上衣服，带它去参加生日派对或成年礼，让黑猩猩进行表演。他们刚结束一场演出正要回家。当时那名男子在开车，黑猩猩坐在副驾驶座上，系着安全带，就像个乘客一样。
And there's lightning and thunder from these storms and the chimpanzee gets a little rattled. And then they have a close lightning strike. Crack. Big, loud boom. And the chimpanzee gets very frightened and comes out of the seat, grabs the driver and yanks him out of the driver's seat and just throws him to the back of the van.
暴风雨带来了闪电和雷声，黑猩猩有点受惊了。接着，一道闪电在近处炸开，轰隆一声巨响。黑猩猩非常害怕，从座位上跳了出来，抓住司机，硬生生把他从驾驶座拽了出来，直接扔到了货车后部。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
（听不清）
Yeah. So then he took the wheel. The chimpanzee was standing between the two seats and is taking the wheel. The man said he was doing really well and then he lost control of the van. And I'm like, the chimpanzee lost control of the van? At what point was the chimpanzee really in charge of this thing? But though he described was, "listen, it's not my fault. The chimpanzee had the accident."
对，然后它就接管了方向盘。黑猩猩站在两个座位之间开始握住方向盘。那人说它开得还挺好，但随后他就失去了对货车的控制。我说，是黑猩猩弄丢了货车的控制权吗？这玩意儿到底什么时候真的由黑猩猩掌舵过？但他当时的描述是：“听着，这不是我的错。是黑猩猩引发了事故。”
So the officer in charge explains to this guy that from the point of view of the law, he was the driver, not the chimp. And he's the one who is going to get charged and the guy's not too happy about that. He leaves the chimp with [? Sean, ?] holding [? Sean's ?] hand, and he walks over to the squad car to sit for a minute inside, just to rest. And the officer in charge notices the guy seems sort of unsteady on his feet.
于是负责的警官告诉他，从法律角度看，他是司机，不是黑猩猩。他才是会被起诉的人，那个人对此很不高兴。他把黑猩猩交给肖恩，让它拉着肖恩的手，然后走回警车想进去坐一会儿，歇一歇。负责的警官注意到那个人走路摇摇晃晃。
And he tells the guy he wants to bring him into the station for a breathalyzer test. This all happened 20 years ago. They couldn't do those kinds of things right there on the side of the road. And the guy starts to raise his voice a little. And the officer in charge just a little testy. It starts to get a little personal between them. The officer informs him that no, he is under arrest until they do this alcohol test. And the guy gets even hotter.
他告诉那个人，要带他回警局做呼气式酒精测试。这一切发生在20年前，当时他们还不能在路边直接做这种测试。那个人开始提高嗓门，负责的警官也有些烦躁。两人之间变得有点剑拔弩张。警官告知他，在做酒精测试前，他必须被拘留。这下那人更火了。
Then he raises his voice and he gets upset and he starts to yell. "This is [BLEEP]. I'm not going to do this. My chimpanzee could be hurt." Blah blah blah. So everybody turns and faces him and the chimpanzee, now his master, is upset. And he's being threatened. And from the back of the crowd, somebody goes, "A chimpanzee can tear a man apart with his bare hands," just from out of the crowd.
他开始大吼大叫：“这简直是扯淡。我才不干这事儿。我的黑猩猩可能会受伤。”诸如此类。所有人都转过身对着他，现在他的主人心烦意乱，正受到威胁。人群后方突然有人喊道：“黑猩猩徒手就能把人撕碎。”就这么从人群中冒出一句。
What?
什么？
Yeah. "A chimpanzee. Look out for the chimpanzee. It could tear a man apart with its bare hands."
对，“黑猩猩。小心那只黑猩猩。它徒手就能把人撕碎。”
Very quickly, the chimpanzee pulls his hand out from my hand and walks pretty forcefully through some people to the back of the car and stands-- squats, rather-- right in front of his owner in the back of the police car with the door open. And we ask the guy, what's the best way to secure him and what can you tell him to make sure that he's OK with this? And the guy's like, "look, nothing. I have never been away from this animal. We've never really been separated. He's not going to react well to this. He could get very excited." And now everybody but myself and the other cop are walking backwards with an eye on the chimp.
那只黑猩猩迅速从我手里抽出手，强行穿过人群来到车后，蹲在警车后座他主人的面前，车门开着。我们问那人，固定住它最好的方法是什么，怎么跟它说才能让它配合？那人说：“看，没用的。我从没离开过这只动物。我们基本没分开过。它不会配合的。它可能会变得非常激动。”现在，除了我和另一名警察，所有人都一边向后退，一边盯着黑猩猩。
When they put the handcuffs on, he was saying, "She is not going to like that. She is not going to like that." And I think the tone of his voice, the chimpanzee started to really not like that. And he turned to display to the chimpanzee that he was in handcuffs.
当他们给他戴上手铐时，他说：“她不会喜欢这样的。她不会喜欢这样的。”我想是他的语气让黑猩猩真的不高兴了。他转身向黑猩猩展示自己被戴上了手铐。
So at this point, the officer in charge asks [? Sean ?] to get emergency services on the radio. They are the ones who have been trained to get an animal under control. And if all else fails, they have a tranquilizer gun.
此时，负责的警官让肖恩通过无线电呼叫紧急救援服务。他们受过专业训练，能控制住动物。如果一切办法都失效，他们还有镇静枪。
So I changed radio frequencies, get them on the air. "Yeah, can you respond up here?" And they're like, "Well, what kind of job is it?" They have all sorts of different tools in the truck and they need to know what to be prepared for too. And I said, "Well, we have a possible DWI, auto accident, and we need you to secure a chimpanzee." And there's just dead silence. And then they just go, no. Because they know me and I think I'm goofing around with them.
于是我切换了无线电频率，接通了他们。“喂，你们能赶过来吗？”他们问：“是什么样的任务？”他们的车里装了各种工具，也需要知道该准备些什么。我说：“我们这儿可能有酒驾、车祸，需要你们来控制一只黑猩猩。”电话那头陷入了死一般的沉寂。然后他们说，不行。因为他们认识我，觉得我在跟他们开玩笑。
He tries again on a land line-- this is before the age of cell phones-- and they hang up again. He has his dispatcher try from the police station's phone. Still no. So now Sean and the other officers on the scene are in this situation where they really have no map at all for what they're supposed to do. It's like a lot of police work, Sean says. You just make it up you go along. You have to. And now the guy's in handcuffs in the back of the squad car.
他又试着用座机联系——那是手机普及之前的年代——他们又挂断了。他又让调度员从警局的电话打过去。还是不行。现在，肖恩和其他在场的警官陷入了完全没有应对预案的处境。肖恩说，就像很多警务工作一样，你只能边做边想办法。没办法。而现在那个人正戴着手铐坐在警车后座。
And the chimpanzee is angry now and kind of bouncing around and shrieking, like chimpanzees-- like Daktari, if you remember the Daktari-- shrieking and running back and forth. And people are running away from the chimpanzee. And I go to the cop, "Look, they're not coming. And you what are you going to do, set this chimp loose on this village?" It could happen. Something could happen. We could end up having to shoot a chimpanzee dressed in a sweatshirt and jeans with shoes on-- a pet-- in a village in front of a hundred people because we think that this guy may have had something to drink. It's a lose-lose, no matter what happens.
黑猩猩现在发怒了，跳来跳去尖叫着，就像黑猩猩那样——如果你记得《达克塔里》（一部关于动物的剧集），它就在那儿尖叫、来回乱窜。人们都在躲着它。我对那个警察说：“听着，他们不会来了。你打算怎么办，把这只黑猩猩放生在这个村子里吗？”什么都有可能发生。我们最后可能不得不在众目睽睽之下，开枪射杀一只穿着运动衫、牛仔裤、带着鞋子的黑猩猩——一只宠物。仅仅因为我们怀疑那个人喝了酒。无论发生什么，这都是个双输的局面。
So he was reluctant because I think he had gotten into a little bit personally with the driver. You know, "You're under arrest and I say you're under arrest." So in the interest of justice and maintaining order, we both kind of decided we're going to un-arrest the guy. Poof, you're un-arrested.
他有些不情愿，因为我觉得他跟司机之间已经有点私人恩怨了。你知道，“你被捕了，我说你被捕了。”所以为了公正和维持秩序，我们俩一致决定要把那个人“解除逮捕”。砰，你不再被捕了。
So they uncuffred the guy and he calms the chimpanzee down. And they're putting him into a car that's going to take him home.
于是他们解开了他的手铐，他安抚好了黑猩猩。他们把他送进一辆车，准备带他回家。
At which point the chimpanzee goes back to the other officer's car, who he didn't like. Opens the door, climbs inside. Underneath his jeans, he has a diaper on. So he takes his diaper off inside the back of the police car where his owner had been. And he smears the diaper all over the inside of the car in full view of the crowd. And it's like purposeful salute from this chimpanzee to the cop.
就在这时，黑猩猩回到刚才那个它不喜欢的警官的车旁。打开车门，钻了进去。在牛仔裤里面，它还穿着尿布。于是它在那个警官刚才坐过的警车后座脱下尿布，当着人群的面，把尿布涂满了车厢内部。那感觉就像是黑猩猩对那个警察进行了一次蓄意的羞辱。
The cop is furious but can do nothing. He's un-arrested somebody that he's arrested. That never happens. A chimpanzee got the last word on a cop. That never happens. The world is upside down. But [? Sean ?] says, what are you going to do? Police work is improvisation. You're put in situations. You have to do something.
警察愤怒至极，却无能为力。他把一个已经逮捕的人又放了。这从没发生过。一只黑猩猩让警察吃了哑巴亏。这从没发生过。世界乱套了。但肖恩说，你能怎么办？警务工作就是临场发挥。你被推向各种处境，你必须得做点什么。
You're the police. You can't just go home. The people, it's what they're paying you for. So you make it up as you're going along, mostly.
你是警察，你不能一走了之。人们付了薪水就是为了让你处理这些，所以大多时候，你只能走一步看一步。
Well, today on our show, situations where capable people find themselves with no map, no precedents they can rely on, no idea how to handle what it is that they're supposed to handle. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. Our show today in two acts-- one in the work world, one at home. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中，我们要聊聊那些能力出众的人却发现自己毫无应对预案、没有任何先例可循，也不知道该如何处理眼前麻烦的情况。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》，由公共广播国际发行。今天的节目分为两幕——一幕关于工作，一幕关于家庭。请继续收听。
Act One, The Mod Squad. We're in the middle of a historic moment where millions of people are losing their homes and the numbers continue to rise. Last month, there were 342,038 foreclosure filings, which is the highest that it's been so far in this recession. And this has left bankers in this situation that they never imagined was going to happen, where they are not entirely clear what to do, and struggling along without any kind of map to handle this situation. They are apparently foreclosing on a lot more people than they need to.
第一幕：调解小组。我们正处于一个历史性时刻，数百万人正在失去家园，而且数字还在不断攀升。上个月，有342,038份抵押品赎回权丧失申请，这是本次经济衰退以来的最高值。这让银行陷入了一种从未预料到的困境，他们不清楚该怎么办，在没有任何预案的情况下苦苦支撑。他们显然正在剥夺比实际必要多得多的人的房屋。
This next number I'm going to tell you is kind of astounding. Some economists, including mainstream academics and Wall Street guys like a chief economist at Moody's, the Wall Street ratings agency, estimate that half-- yes, half-- of all the six million possible foreclosures that we're facing over the next three years don't need to happen. That even the banks would be better off, they would make more money, they would come out richer if they didn't foreclose. Reporter Chris Arnold explains how this could possibly be.
接下来我要说的这个数字相当惊人。一些经济学家，包括主流学者和像穆迪公司（华尔街评级机构）首席经济学家那样的华尔街人士估计，我们未来三年面临的600万宗潜在抵押品赎回权丧失案例中，有一半——没错，是一半——其实根本不必发生。甚至连银行自己如果选择不剥夺赎回权，反而会从中获益更多，会更富有。记者克里斯·阿诺德将为您解释这是怎么回事。
To illustrate the paradox of this crisis, here's this couple. I met them at a foreclosure prevention event. The foreclosure mess is now so huge that these events are happening all over the country.
为了说明这场危机的悖论，我们来看看这对夫妇。我是在一场防范抵押品赎回权丧失的活动上认识他们的。现在房产丧失抵押品赎回权的问题实在太严重，类似的活动在全国各地都在举行。
My name is Alex [? Alicea. ?] I am a truck driver for [UNINTELLIGIBLE] Slab and Marble Company in Bridgeport. And I don't know what to do. This is my last alternative, coming here.
我叫亚历克斯·阿利西亚（音译）。我是布里奇波特一家板材大理石公司的卡车司机。我不知道该怎么办。来这里是我最后的选择。
Every eight seconds, another house gets foreclosed in the US. So banks and nonprofits hold big events like this. This one was at a hotel in Connecticut. Thousands of people showed up. There's about a hundred housing counselors with laptop computers spread out across this big convention hall at little tables.
在美国，每八秒钟就有一处房产被剥夺赎回权。所以银行和非营利组织会举办这样的大型活动。这场活动在康涅狄格州的一家酒店举行。成千上万的人赶来。大会展厅里摆着小桌子，约有一百名住房咨询顾问带着笔记本电脑坐在那里。
All right, what I'm going to do right now, Alex, is that I'm going to pull your credit report.
好的，我现在要做的，亚历克斯，是查询你的信用报告。
Alex isn't one of these people who bought a house that he couldn't afford. He says he's had steady work as a truck driver for 15 years, but he refinanced a couple of times, pulled out some money to fix up the house and pay some bills. Then his wife lost her job and now they can't afford their monthly payments. On top of that, their house has lost value. They owe $230,000 on their home loan and their house is only worth 180,000.
亚历克斯并不是那种买了他负担不起的房子的人。他说他做了15年稳定的卡车司机，但为了装修房子和支付账单，他做过几次再融资，取了一些钱出来。后来他妻子失业了，现在他们付不起每月的贷款了。更糟的是，房子贬值了。他们的房屋贷款欠款是23万美元，但房子只值18万美元。
It's not worth staying in the house. If the house is only going to be worth 180 and I'm going to be paying a mortgage of $230,000?
留在这房子里太不划算了。如果房子只值18万，而我却要付23万的抵押贷款？
Alex is underwater. Sometimes it's called upside down. You hear those terms a lot nowadays and, in fact, you'll hear them again before this story's over. Somewhere between 15-20% of all homeowners are in the situation. They owe more than their house is worth. Alex is so stressed out that he's taking medication and having trouble sleeping. He's the first person in his family to own a home and now he's about to lose it.
亚历克斯处于“水下”状态。有时也被称为“倒挂”。你现在经常听到这些词，事实上，在这个故事结束前你还会听到。所有房主中，大约有15%到20%的人处于这种境地。他们欠的钱比房子本身的价值还要多。亚历克斯压力大到需要服药，还经常失眠。他是家里第一个有房的人，现在却即将失去它。
And here's what's so strange. Alex shouldn't be losing his house. Not out of some doe-eyed feeling of charity, not because hard-working people deserve homes, but for a simple economic reason. The bank doesn't want his house-- or whoever owns his mortgage. If they take his house back, they'd have to sell it for a big loss. It makes much more financial sense to cut him a deal. And this is the thing-- this is the crazy thing about this whole foreclosure mess. In a lot of cases, it would be a win-win to cut people deals, that is, to lower their payments and keep them in their homes. Then the lender would keep getting payments and it would have the added benefit of helping the housing market and possibly saving the economy. But it's not happening. The system isn't working right.
奇怪的地方就在这里。亚历克斯本不该失去房子。这并非出于某种天真的慈善想法，也不是因为勤劳工作的人就理应拥有家园，而是出于一个简单的经济学原因。银行——或者说持有他贷款的人——并不想要他的房子。如果他们收回房子，转手卖掉会亏一大笔。跟他达成某种协议在经济上更有意义。这就是整个抵押品赎回权丧失乱局中最疯狂的地方：在很多情况下，给人们达成协议，即降低他们的还款额并让他们继续住在房子里，是双赢的局面。这样贷款方能继续收到还款，而且还能起到帮助房产市场甚至拯救经济的作用。但这种情况并没有发生。系统并没有正常运转。
In some ways, the system was designed to work on autopilot.
在某些方面，这个系统被设计为依靠自动驾驶模式运转。
That's Mark Pearce. He's North Carolina's deputy banking commissioner. And he says it's a huge problem. Mark Pearce has been meeting with executives at all the major banks and mortgage companies. And he's been getting the industry's own data on foreclosures. And what he's seeing is huge numbers of people in roughly the situation that Alex [? Alicea ?] is in. They're facing foreclosure even though they have jobs and could make some kind of reasonable payments. And it would be in everyone's interest just to rewrite their terms. But so far, that's not happening.
那是马克·皮尔斯。他是北卡罗来纳州的副银行专员。他说这是一个巨大的问题。马克·皮尔斯一直在与各大银行和抵押贷款公司的高管会面。他获得了该行业关于抵押品赎回权丧失的内部数据。他看到有大量的人处在与亚历克斯·阿利西亚大致相同的情况下。他们面临抵押品赎回权丧失，尽管他们有工作，本可以支付合理的款项。如果能重写条款，这对每个人都有利。但到目前为止，这并没有发生。
Unfortunately, only 5-10% of the people that probably need the help are actually getting something that's going to enable them to stay in their home. The other 90-95% of homeowners, the way the system has worked has simply been to push those homeowners into foreclosure. And rather than making any deal at all, the system drives them to lose their home.
不幸的是，在可能需要帮助的人中，只有5%到10%真正得到了能让他们保住房子的帮助。对于其余90%到95%的房主来说，系统的运作方式就是简单地将他们推向失去抵押品赎回权。系统不仅没有达成任何协议，反而迫使他们失去家园。
There are so far today almost 3,000 calls-- have come in just to home retention. It's 3:30.
到今天为止，仅住房保留部门就已经接到了近3000个电话。现在是下午3点半。
Danny Shapone is a manager at a call center run by a company named Ocwen. And I came here to find out, basically, what the hell's going on. Why, when the industry is presented with-- let's be honest-- a rare case of an actual win-win, why is everybody still losing?
丹尼·沙蓬是一家名为Ocwen的贷款公司所运营呼叫中心的经理。我来到这里，主要是想搞清楚到底发生了什么。当行业面临——坦白说——一个罕见的双赢局面时，为什么所有人都在受损？
Thank you, and the phone call may be recorded. This isn't an attempt to collect a debt--
谢谢，通话可能会被录音。这不是催债行为——
This is ground zero of the foreclosure crisis-- right here. If you own a house and you send in your mortgage payment, it comes to a company like this one. They're called a loan servicer. You may not know that. Most people have never heard of a loan servicer. You think you're writing a check and it goes to the bank that loaned the money. But these days, there's the person who gave you the mortgage, then often, they sold it to somebody else and then they sold it to somebody else. And so the person who eventually gets your money, you have no idea.
这里是抵押品赎回权危机的主战场。如果你有房子并寄送了抵押贷款，它就会汇到像这样的一家公司。他们被称为贷款服务商。你可能不知道这一点。大多数人从未听说过贷款服务商。你以为你开了一张支票，钱就直接到了放贷的银行。但现在，情况是：借给你贷款的人，通常会把贷款卖给别人，那个人又把它卖给别人。所以，最终收到你钱的人是谁，你根本无从知晓。
It turns out Ocwen does. They're the middleman between you and the person that you owe. They're are also the people that you call when you can't pay. Or they'll call you. They're a debt collector
Ocwen却是知道的。他们是你和你所欠债主之间的中间人。当你付不起贷款时，你打给的就是他们。或者他们会打给你。他们是收债人。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语对话）
It's a big room-- lots of cubicles, call center workers with headsets. Ocwen's got 300 people taking calls-- twice as many as two years ago. All day, they talk to people who are about to lose their homes. It's their job to figure out if it makes sense to modify their loans, lower their payments to avoid a foreclosure.
这是一个大办公室——里面有很多隔间，呼叫中心的工作人员戴着耳机。Ocwen有300人在接电话——是两年前的两倍。他们整天都在与那些即将失去家园的人交谈。他们的工作是判断修改贷款条款是否合理，降低还款额以避免失去抵押品赎回权。
Ocwen agreed to talk to us probably because they're different than a lot of loan servicers in one important way. When you have trouble with your loan and call Ocwen, they might actually help you out. They modify a lot of mortgages. They say when a borrower can't pay, 75% of the time, they work out a deal that keeps them in their homes. In other words, they do loan modifications for three times as many people as they are foreclosing on.
Ocwen同意与我们交谈，大概是因为他们与许多贷款服务商在一个重要的方面有所不同。当你的贷款遇到困难打给Ocwen时，他们确实可能帮你一把。他们修改了很多抵押贷款。他们表示，在借款人无力支付时，75%的情况下，他们能达成协议让借款人继续留在自己的房子里。换句话说，他们贷款修改的人数是他们剥夺抵押品赎回权人数的三倍。
Margery Rotundo is a vice president who's in charge of the call center. She shows us Ocwen's computer system. This is where they crunch the numbers that allow them to be nice to people.
玛吉·罗通多是呼叫中心的副总裁。她向我们展示了Ocwen的计算机系统。这就是他们计算数据的地方，这套数据能让他们表现得“仁慈”。
So here's the other financial information that we gather, your monthly food, electric, cable.
所以，这是我们收集的其他财务信息，你的每月伙食费、电费、有线电视费。
Basically, every borrower is in a database. And when they call asking for a modification, it's as simple as plugging in a few numbers. Ocwen finds out what their income is and how much they owe. And then based on those two things, Ocwen figures what the homeowner can afford to pay. Then they try to rework the loan terms to match that number. They can reduce the interest, which is sometimes as high as 11 or 12% to as low as 2%. And just like that, this can cut a person's monthly payment in half. Sometimes-- and this is more rare, just 16% of the time-- Ocwen even reduces the actual amount that the person owes.
基本上，每个借款人都在数据库里。当他们打电话寻求修改时，只需要输入几个数字就这么简单。Ocwen会查清他们的收入和债务。然后根据这两点，Ocwen算出房主能负担的支付额。之后他们会尝试重写贷款条款以匹配这个数字。他们可以将利息从有时高达11%或12%降低到2%。就这么简单，这能将一个人的每月还款额削减一半。有时——这种情况更罕见，仅占16%——Ocwen甚至会减少借款人实际欠下的本金总额。
Ocwen can do all this because if they did nothing and allowed the foreclosure process to run its course, it would cost even more. Margery points to a computer screen that actually calculates how much money would be lost in a foreclosure for one of their loans. The software knows what the average repair costs are for foreclosed properties in any given neighborhood. It calculates the legal fees.
Ocwen之所以能这样做，是因为如果他们什么都不做，任由抵押品赎回权丧失程序走到底，成本会更高。玛吉指向电脑屏幕，上面计算着一笔贷款在丧失抵押品赎回权时会损失多少钱。软件知道任何特定社区里收回房产后的平均维修成本。它会计算法律费用。
Your broker fees, once you sell it, is going to be $6,300. The closing costs, 1,837.
你的经纪人费用，一旦卖掉，将是6300美元。过户费，1837美元。
What's the repair?
维修费是多少？
On the repairs, $2,500 on a single family home. And then the legal fees and costs associated with taking completing a foreclosure, $275 in legal fees and $975 in legal costs.
维修费方面，单户住宅是2500美元。然后是与完成抵押品赎回权丧失相关的法律费用和支出，275美元的律师费和975美元的法律支出。
The argument for making a deal with the homeowner looks even better when you consider how much value the house has lost. That's huge. Say I'm the bank and a borrower owes me $400,000 on a mortgage. But it now turns out that the house is only worth half that. If I foreclose, I own a house that I can only sell for $200,000. I've lost at least half my money. So even if I cut the homeowner an incredible deal-- I tell them forget about $50,000 or even $100,000 of that 400 that he owes me-- I still come out ahead. I've lost less money. It's all there in the numbers on Margery's computer screen.
考虑到房价下跌的程度，与房主达成协议的论据看起来就更充分了。这太严重了。假设我是银行，借款人欠我40万美元的房贷。但现在房子只值一半。如果我剥夺抵押品赎回权，我就会拥有一套只能卖20万美元的房子。我至少损失了一半的钱。所以即使我给房主达成一个极好的协议——比如我告诉他免除那40万中的5万甚至10万——我依然是赚的。我的损失更小了。这一切都在玛吉的电脑屏幕上呈现。
I hit calculate and in less than one second, it ran the net present values.
我点击计算，不到一秒钟，它就运行出了净现值。
When you see Margery's database, it looks very straightforward and mathematical. But out in the call center, it gets very messy and human and complicated pretty fast. My producer Alex Blumberg and I talked to Danny Shapone and another manager, Doug [? Donegan ?] They say they hear all kinds of heartbreaking stories from people-- a lost job or an unexpected medical cost, victims of a mortgage scam. Then there are the non-heartbreaking ones.
当你看到玛吉的数据库时，它看起来非常直观且数学化。但在呼叫中心外面，情况变得非常混乱、人性化且复杂。我的制片人亚历克斯·布伦伯格和我与丹尼·沙蓬以及另一位经理道格·多尼根谈过。他们说他们听过各种令人心碎的故事——失业或意想不到的医疗开支，抵押贷款骗局的受害者。然后还有一些让人不太心碎的。
We had somebody who had all the money in the world, the ability to pay, sent in their bank statements, we were looking at it. And I think it was about eight cash withdrawals at the Hard Rock Casino down the road here in a three-day period. So this is somebody who was there--
我们遇到过一个人，他明明有钱，有能力支付，也寄来了银行对账单，我们审视了一番。我记得在三天内，他在附近的一家硬石赌场（Hard Rock Casino）有八次提现记录。所以这个人当时在那里——
Casino ATM with a $10 fee, I mean--
赌场ATM手续费要10美元，我的意思是——
Eight times in three days. So you're there, you lose it, you go to the money machine, you get more, several times in one day. But you're not, in the back of your head, thinking, I'm going to have trouble making my mortgage payment.
三天内取了八次。所以你人在那儿，输了钱，去取款机取更多，一天好几次。但你脑子里完全没想过，我会还不起房贷。
So ultimately, I think she told us, she's like, "Yeah, I have a gambling problem. I'm going to get help." But that's not the norm. Most borrowers aren't like, oh yeah, I have a gambling problem.
最后，我想她告诉我们：“是的，我有赌博成瘾。我会去寻求帮助。”但那不是常态。大多数借款人不会说，噢对，我有赌博问题。
But it is a prioritization of finances. We have people that tell us how desperate and how they have no money and no ability. And we look at their bank statements and they're going to P.F. Chang's and Ruby Tuesdays and, yeah, Starbucks, 7-11. Like Danny's mentioned, you go to 7-11 a couple times a week. That adds up to $50 really fast, but nobody's thinking about that. They're not changing their habits to adjust to the reduction in income. Instead of changing habits, they're changing paying.
但这确实是财务优先顺序的问题。有些人告诉我们他们有多绝望，多么没钱、多么无能为力。但我们看他们的银行对账单，他们去P.F. Chang's餐厅、Ruby Tuesdays、还有星巴克、7-11。就像丹尼提到的，你一周去几次7-11。那很快就加起来有50美元了，但没人会考虑到这点。他们没有改变习惯以适应收入减少的情况。他们没有改变习惯，而是改变了还款习惯。
Ocwen is just one company, just one loan servicer that's gotten [? religion ?] about doing a lot of these workouts. The problem is there are dozens of other loan servicers. The biggest ones are owned by the big banks-- Wells Fargo, Citigroup, Chase-- the same banks that are getting bailed out by the government right now. They all have big servicing divisions. We sat down with the top executives at Ocwen-- president Ron Faris and executive vice president Paul Koches-- in their modest conference room. They said those bigger companies, the big banks, it turns out they were just not set up to deal with this problem.
Ocwen只是一家公司，只是众多贷款服务商中，开始“信仰”并进行大量此类债务重组的一家。问题在于还有几十家其他的贷款服务商。最大的那些是由大银行拥有的——富国银行、花旗集团、大通银行——就是那些现在正被政府救助的大银行。它们都有庞大的服务部门。我们在Ocwen不起眼的会议室里采访了总裁罗恩·法里斯和执行副总裁保罗·科切斯。他们说，那些更大的公司，那些大银行，结果发现它们根本没准备好处理这个问题。
But let me give you a story here-- happened actually right here in this very room. And unfortunately, I think it's probably not appropriate for me to say the name. But one of the largest servicers and commercial banks in the country came down to visit and sat in this very room. And this was probably back in about mid-2007 when, clearly, people were starting to see signs that trouble was ahead.
我给你讲个故事——其实就发生在这个房间里。不幸的是，我想我不便透露名字。但全国最大的服务商和商业银行之一来访，就坐在在这个房间里。那大概是在2007年中期，当时人们显然已经开始看到危机在前的迹象了。
And what they said to us was, "the reason we're here today is because we know that delinquencies are rising. We know that we're are not going to be able to hire enough experienced collectors. And to compound that, we don't have any real loss mitigation type technology. We have just the basic, core servicing technology that collects in a payment each month and sends out a statement. And it works really well when people make a payment every day. But we don't have all of that mathematical stuff that you're talking about-- the models or whatever. And we're not sure what to do because we're pretty sure that by the time we get it implemented, it'll be too late."
他们对我们说：“我们今天来这里是因为我们知道违约率在上升。我们知道我们将无法雇佣到足够有经验的催收人员。雪上加霜的是，我们没有任何真正的损失减轻类技术。我们只有基本的、核心的服务技术，每月收一笔钱并寄出账单。当人们每天都付款时，它运作得很好。但我们没有你所说的那种数学工具——那些模型之类的。我们不知道该怎么办，因为我们非常确信，等我们实施的时候，已经太晚了。”
So they sat here and were literally like, "we're not sure what to do and we want to talk to you about how could you possibly help us?" That's the kind of situation that we we're dealing with them and I'm talking about one of the largest banks in the world sat here in this room and told us that story.
所以他们坐在那儿，简直就像是说：“我们不知道该怎么办，我们想跟你谈谈，你们怎么可能帮我们？”这就是我们面对他们时的那种境况，我指的是全球最大的银行之一坐在我们这个房间里，讲了这个故事。
Was that surprising for you to hear? Here you are servicing a few hundred thousand loans. One of the largest banks in the country that's dealing with millions of loans at a time when this foreclosure crisis is mounting, and they're basically saying, well, if everybody pays on time, everything's great, but we really don't have the systems in place to deal with it if people stop paying.
听到这些你感到惊讶吗？你这边管理着几十万笔贷款。而全国最大的银行之一在处理数百万笔贷款时，正值抵押品赎回权危机加剧之时，他们居然说，如果大家都按时付款一切都好，但如果人们停止付款，我们真的没有系统来处理它。
It was eye-opening to hear them actually acknowledge it and say it and say that they have a problem and they weren't sure what to do.
听到他们真正承认并说出来，说他们有问题且不知道该怎么办，这真的很令人大开眼界。
Ocwen, on the other hand, has been doing this for a while. For their entire history, they've specialized in so-called distressed debt, which means that they're the industry's problem loan guys. They were like the messed up loan foreclosure specialists. Before this crisis, that was a tiny part of the market. Now it is the market. Vice president Paul Koches says he was at a meeting in Washington recently. The industry was batting around the notion of a celebrity campaign. This was their big idea, to get celebrities to go on TV and tell people at risk of foreclosure to call up their lenders and ask about loan workouts.
另一方面，Ocwen已经做这个很久了。在他们的整个历史中，他们专门处理所谓的“不良债务”，这意味着他们是业内的问题贷款专家。他们就像是那种棘手贷款的抵押品赎回权丧失专家。在这场危机之前，这只是市场上极小的一部分。现在，这就是整个市场。副总裁保罗·科切斯说他最近在华盛顿参加了一个会议。业界正在讨论一个明星宣传活动的概念。这是他们想出的一个大招：找明星上电视，告诉那些面临抵押品赎回权丧失风险的人，让他们打给贷款人询问贷款重组的事。
And this is very well attended-- all the usual suspects, all the the big banks-- and there was one person who, on behalf of a very large bank, almost in an excited sort of utterance just blurted, he said, "well, you can't do that. If you're successful in drumming up all this interest on the part of the homeowners who need help, we won't be able to handle the volume."
这次会议参会者众多——所有常见的那些怀疑对象，所有大银行——有一位代表某大型银行的人，几乎是在一种兴奋的脱口而出：“哦，你们不能那么做。如果你成功调动了所有需要帮助的房主的积极性，我们将无法应付这个数量。”
The level of the market disruption just caught many servicers by surprise. And indeed, we're still getting our systems in order in order to be able to handle the massive levels of defaults.
市场混乱的程度让许多服务商措手不及。事实上，我们仍在整理我们的系统，以便能够处理如此大规模的违约。
That's Rod Alba, the vice president for mortgage finance at the American Bankers Association, which represents banks around the country. I called him up and he basically agrees with all of this, that a lot more loan modifications would make good business sense. But still, two years into this mess, many big loan servicers haven't figured out how to make that happen. And there are a lot of other reasons that the big banks, which are also the biggest loan servicers, aren't modifying more mortgages. Because of the way accounting rules work, if they do a loan modification, they basically rewrite the terms of the loan, which means that then they have to admit that they have a problem on their hands.
那是美国银行家协会抵押贷款金融副总裁罗德·阿尔巴，该协会代表全国各地的银行。我打电话给他，他基本同意这一切，即进行更多的贷款修改在商业上是合情合理的。但是，即便在这个烂摊子里待了两年，许多大型贷款服务商仍未找到实现这一目标的方法。而且，那些既是银行又是最大贷款服务商的大银行不进行更多贷款修改，还有许多其他原因。由于会计准则的运作方式，如果他们进行贷款修改，他们基本上就是重写贷款条款，这意味着他们必须承认自己手头上有问题。
And if I engage in an actual modification, now I have a distressed assets. And if I have a distressed asset, then that gives me a knock to the capital base. That is proving to be one of the problems in this area.
如果我进行实际的修改，现在我就有了一项不良资产。如果我有一项不良资产，那就会给资本基础造成打击。事实证明，这是该领域的问题之一。
It's a problem because the bank has to take a short-term loss. If they don't modify the loan and put the house in foreclosure, they still take a loss-- and probably a bigger loss-- but it might be as much as a year under accounting rules before that law shows up on their books. They still lose money, but they don't lose it now. And it's now that the banks are worried about.
这是个问题，因为银行必须承担短期损失。如果他们不修改贷款，而是进行抵押品赎回权丧失处理，他们依然会遭受损失——而且可能是更大的损失——但根据会计准则，这笔损失可能要过一年才会出现在他们的账簿上。他们依然会赔钱，但不是现在。而银行担心的是现在。
And then and there are those conflicts of interest. Some top people in the mortgage business think those are a big problem.
此外还有那些利益冲突。抵押贷款行业的一些高层认为这是个大问题。
Well, it closely resembles, in some ways, the fox guarding the hen house.
嗯，在某些方面，这很像“引狼入室”。
This is Scott Simon. He's not the NPR host and he's not a consumer advocate or an anti-bank activist. He's a big time money guy. He's a managing director at Pimco. It's an investment firm that holds more than $500 billion worth of home mortgages in the form of mortgage backed securities. Simon manages all of that. He says often the banks are servicing loans that are owned by investors like him. And the banks are supposed to make sure that the investors get paid. And they're supposed to decide if a loan modification makes good business sense. Simon thinks they should be making more loan modifications but he believes that the banks are wearing too many hats and they can't do that job right.
这是斯科特·西蒙。他不是NPR的主持人，也不是消费者权益倡导者或反银行活动人士。他是一个重量级的金融大鳄。他是PIMCO的董事总经理。这是一家投资公司，持有超过5000亿美元的以抵押贷款支持证券形式存在的住房抵押贷款。西蒙管理着这一切。他说，通常银行在为像他这样的投资者拥有的贷款提供服务。银行本应确保投资者拿到钱。他们本应决定贷款修改在商业上是否合理。西蒙认为他们应该进行更多的贷款修改，但他相信银行承担了太多的角色，他们无法胜任那份工作。
So take an example. You have a $300,000 house that's only worth $260,000 and it might make all the sense in the world to modify that loan. It's good for the investor, good for the homeowner. But it turns out that the bank that services the loan has also lent the person $25,000 on a home equity line of credit.
举个例子。你有一套30万美元的房子只值26万美元，修改那笔贷款可能完全合理。这对投资者和房主都有好处。但事实证明，负责该贷款的银行也已经向此人贷了2.5万美元的住房净值授信额度。
A home equity line of credit is, of course, a second mortgage. You borrow another, say, $25,000 to redo your kitchen, buy a car or just pay off your credit cards with your house as collateral.
住房净值授信额度当然就是第二抵押贷款。你再借个比如2.5万美元来重新装修厨房、买车，或者只是用你的房子作抵押来还清信用卡账单。
The problem becomes that the bank has much more interest in their $25,000 line of credit and helping the homeowner or the investor, in this case.
问题在于，银行对他们那2.5万的信贷额度的兴趣，远大于帮助房主或投资者。
Simon says legally, it can be tough to modify your mortgage without basically wiping out your home equity loan. And some of the nation's biggest banks are each on the hook for more than $100 billion of those little home equity loans. And so he says the bank is a big incentive to avoid doing a modification. And so it doesn't happen.
西蒙说，在法律上，如果不彻底清算你的住房净值贷款，很难修改你的抵押贷款。而全国一些最大的银行，每家都背负着超过1000亿美元的此类小型住房净值贷款。因此他说，银行有巨大的动力去避免进行修改。所以事情就没成。
Everybody is trying to protect their own self-interest. And ultimately, the conflicts keep it from happening. The servicers enable this to occur or can essentially veto this from occurring. And so what's in their interest really is dominating the day. You just look at it and say, hey why can't we just fix this?
每个人都在试图保护自己的私利。最终，利益冲突阻碍了这一切的发生。服务商促成了这种情况，或者本质上可以否决它的发生。所以，真正支配这一天的，是他们的自身利益。你看看就会说，嘿，为什么我们不能解决这个问题呢？
We talked to several of the biggest banks but none of them would let us come do interviews at their loan servicing operations. In prepared statements, the banks point to all the loan adjustments that they are making right now. And these are on the rise and most loan modifications now do result in lower monthly payments.
我们采访了几家最大的银行，但没有一家允许我们去他们的贷款服务部门进行采访。在准备好的声明中，银行指出了他们目前正在进行的所有贷款调整。这些调整正在增加，而且现在大多数贷款修改确实导致了每月还款额的降低。
But as Mark Pearce, the deputy banking regulator said earlier, only one in 10 of the people who need loan modifications are getting them. And when the banks and big loan servicers do modify loans, regulators say that too often, they're not taking the dramatic steps that actually keep people in their houses-- the things that Ocwen does, slashing interest rates or lowering the overall amount of loans. And because the big banks don't take those steps, 46% of the modified loans have ended up in trouble again.
但正如监管银行事务的副专员马克·皮尔斯早些时候所说，每10个需要贷款修改的人中只有1个得到了帮助。当银行和大型贷款服务商修改贷款时，监管机构表示，他们往往没有采取真正能让人们保住房子的重大举措——比如Ocwen所做的那些事：大幅削减利率或降低贷款总额。而由于大银行没有采取这些步骤，46%的修改后的贷款最终再次出现了问题。
Of course, the scale of this problem is just by its very nature overwhelming. And you can see that at the call center at Ocwen.
当然，这个问题本身的规模之大令人无法承受。你在Ocwen的呼叫中心就能看到这一点。
I'm not saying that you haven't been trying, but the last payment that we received that's been applied to your account was in October of '08.
我并不是说你没有尝试，但我们收到的应用到你账户的最后一笔付款是在08年10月。
Call center worker Tammy White has been going around and around trying to do something that sounds like it should be pretty simple-- get a copy of an old tax return from a homeowner who's looking to get her payments lowered.
呼叫中心工作人员塔米·怀特一直反复尝试做一件听起来应该很简单的事情——从一名寻求降低还款额的房主那里获取一份旧的纳税申报单复印件。
Look, I didn't say I didn't receive it. I said it wasn't signed. And that could have been what got you in the situation that you're in today. Thank you. Bye bye.
看，我没说我没收到。我说的是它没签字。而那可能就是导致你今天这种处境的原因。谢谢，再见。
Can we talk about that call for a second? What's the story there?
我们能谈谈那个电话吗？怎么回事？
She was asking why we need all this because she didn't have to provide any of it when she got her loan. And I was trying to explain to her that's why she's probably in this bad situation.
她在问为什么我们需要这一切，因为她在贷款时根本不需要提供任何这些东西。我试图向她解释，这大概就是为什么她现在的境况这么糟糕。
So this conversation takes half an hour to try to get one homeowner to sign and mail in one document. This is the conversation that has to happen millions of times if we're going to sort all this out. That's not an easy thing. But the people here at Ocwen say it's definitely doable. The Obama administration has a new plan to try to get a lot more loan modifications happening. But for now, we're still in the middle of this giant foreclosure mess. People are losing their houses at a faster rate every month, another one every eight seconds.
所以这次谈话花了半小时试图让一名房主签署并寄回一份文件。如果我们要解决所有这些问题，这样的对话必须发生数百万次。这绝非易事。但Ocwen的这些人说这绝对是可行的。奥巴马政府有一个新计划，试图让更多的贷款修改发生。但目前，我们仍处于这个巨大的抵押品赎回权丧失乱局中。人们失去房子的速度每个月都在加快，每八秒钟就有一个。
Chris Arnold is a reporter for NPR News. His story is part of Planet Money, which is a co-production that our show is doing with NPR News. You can have the economy explained to you in normal human language. They're even funny on their podcast thrice weekly at www.npr.org/money.
克里斯·阿诺德是NPR新闻的记者。他的报道是“金钱星球”的一部分，这是我们节目与NPR新闻共同制作的内容。你可以用普通人的语言听懂经济学。他们甚至在每周三次的播客里也很有趣，网址是 www.npr.org/money。
Coming up, parenting stumpers. Match your wits against some very well-intentioned parents. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来是育儿难题。看看你能否与一些动机良好的父母斗智斗勇。来自芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际的节目稍后继续。
Well, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme and bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, No Map. Stories of people struggling through situations where there are no guideposts or precedents.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，并为你带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的主题是：没有地图。讲述的是人们在没有指南或先例的情况下，在困境中挣扎的故事。
We've arrived Act Two of our show. Act Two, Where's King Solomon When You Need Him? It's not like there's not a map for how to handle being a parent. Our culture's actually awash with how-to parenting guides. It's actually kind of comforting. If any jackass can have a kid, I can have a kid. Anything that comes up, somebody has already dealt with. You'll be able to get advice. Unless you're a guy in this story, Mike Nyberg.
我们进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕：当你需要所罗门王时，他在哪里？并不是说育儿没有地图。我们的文化中实际上充斥着育儿指南。这其实挺让人欣慰的。如果任何笨蛋都能养孩子，那我也能。任何出现的问题，别人都已经处理过了。你总能得到建议。除非你像这个故事里的家伙，迈克·奈伯格一样。
Over the course of four years, he got into a series of situations and faced a series of parenting decisions in adopting a child that were so unusual, so difficult, that it really seems that he was lost at sea in almost uncharted parenting territory. Ted Gesing tells us what happened.
在四年时间里，他经历了一系列的情况，在领养孩子时面临了一系列育儿决定。这些决定非常不寻常，非常困难，以至于他看起来真的像是在近乎未知的育儿领域里迷失了方向。泰德·格辛为我们讲述了发生的一切。
Mike and Kari Nyberg already had two sons. They're Mormon, or LDS-- Latter Day Saints. And when they decided to adopt, they begin to look at children from Samoa, a small Pacific island that has a large LDS population. Mike remembers the first picture he saw of the three year old they would eventually name Elleia.
迈克和卡莉·奈伯格已经有了两个儿子。他们是摩门教徒，或者叫LDS——后期圣徒。当他们决定领养时，他们开始关注来自萨摩亚的孩子，这是一个拥有大量LDS人口的太平洋小岛。迈克记得他第一次看到那个三岁女孩照片时的样子，他们后来给她取名艾莉娅。
I saw a cute little girl with a pair of pants that seemed to be cut off at about the knees. She didn't have a shirt on. Her bangs were trimmed really short. Looked like kind of a hack job.
我看到一个可爱的女孩，穿着一条看起来大概在膝盖处就被剪短了的裤子。她没穿上衣。刘海剪得特别短。看起来像是瞎剪的。
What was your understanding of some of these kids' situations? Did they have families or no?
你对这些孩子的处境有什么了解？他们有家人吗？
We were told that they did have families and that their families we're giving them up because of their financial circumstance-- that they wanted a better life for their child, they were not able to provide food for their children.
我们被告知他们确实有家人，而且家人是因为经济状况才放弃他们的——他们希望为孩子提供更好的生活，他们无法负担孩子的食物。
Elleia was the youngest of eight kids. The adoption agency Mike and Kari chose in Salt Lake City, called Focus on Children, told them that Elleia had been living for the past nine months in the agency's nanny house where a Samoan couple took care of the children. But when the time came for them to go pick her up, Mike and Kari were told that Samoa and the nanny house were off limits because of a recent hurricane. They would have to meet the girl at the closest major airport in New Zealand. They flew there and waited for Elleia's flight.
艾莉娅是八个孩子中最小的。迈克和卡莉在盐湖城选择的那家名叫“关注孩子”（Focus on Children）的领养机构告诉他们，艾莉娅过去九个月一直住在该机构的保姆房里，由一对萨摩亚夫妇照顾。但当他们去接她时，迈克和卡莉被告知，因为飓风，萨摩亚和保姆房暂时无法进入。他们必须在新西兰最近的主要机场接这个女孩。他们飞到那里，等待艾莉娅的航班。
We picked Elleia up at the airport at one o'clock in the morning. And we waited and waited. Everybody came off the airplane. And finally, here came this little girl in a little blue dress, little straps on his shoulders, and she was holding a little orange basketball. And she just looked so sad, but we were so excited. I had the camcorder going. She kept repeating the words [SPEAKING SAMOAN].
我们在凌晨一点在机场接到了艾莉娅。我们等啊等。所有人都下了飞机。最后，走出来这个穿着蓝色小裙子、肩膀上有小带子的小女孩，她手里拿着一个橙色的小篮球。她看起来那么难过，但我们太兴奋了。我开着摄像机。她一直在重复说[萨摩亚语]。
Not knowing Samoan-- not knowing any Samoan at all-- we had no idea what she was saying, couldn't communicate with her.
不懂萨摩亚语——完全不懂——我们根本不知道她在说什么，无法与她交流。
They took her back to their hotel and did what the adoption agency had instructed them, which was to rub her down with a lotion that would kill off scabies.
他们把她带回酒店，并按照领养机构的指示做了：给她擦拭一种能杀死疥疮的乳液。
So here we have this little girl who hasn't reached her fourth birthday quite yet and these two white people, we've stripped her down to nothing and we're rubbing this lotion all over her body, into her hair, into her scalp, and she's just scared to death. And I never forget sitting in that love seat and rocking her while she said that, [SPEAKING SAMOAN], not knowing what she was saying, and she finally fell asleep.
所以我们这里有个还没到四岁的小女孩，而我们这两个白人，把她脱得精光，全身都抹上这种乳液，抹进头发里，抹进头皮里，她简直吓坏了。我永远忘不了坐在那张双人沙发上，一边晃着她，一边听她说着[萨摩亚语]，不知道她在说什么，最后她睡着了。
So our goal the following day was to go out and find somebody that spoke Samoan. We finally found out that one of the waiters in the restaurant in the hotel we were staying was from Samoa. And so he talked to her a little bit. And he proceeded to tell us that [SPEAKING SAMOAN] means I want Tupu. Tupu was her mother. And so she was merely saying, I want my mom. And who wouldn't? She would hold my hand as we walked down the street, but she I think she really felt like what we were going to do is we were going to take her back where she came from, because she always wanted to go. She would actually pick up that little basketball that she had and she would walk over and squat down next to the door and just wait like we were getting ready to leave.
所以我们第二天的目标是出去找一个会说萨摩亚语的人。我们最终发现酒店餐馆里的一名服务员来自萨摩亚。于是他跟她说了几句话。他接着告诉我们，[萨摩亚语]的意思是“我想要图普”。图普是她的母亲。所以她只是在说，我想要我的妈妈。谁不会呢？她会拉着我的手走在街上，但我认为她真的觉得我们要做的就是把她带回她来的地方，因为她总是想走。她甚至会捡起那个小篮球，走到门边蹲下，就像我们准备要离开一样。
Within days, they were back in Utah, and Elleia begin to settle into her new life. She was doing well, Mike said, and she picked up English incredibly quickly. It only took her about a month. And that's when things begin to change for the Nybergs.
几天之内，他们回到了犹他州，艾莉娅开始适应她的新生活。迈克说，她表现得很好，而且英语学得快得惊人。只花了一个月。就在那时，奈伯格夫妇的生活开始发生变化。
She started to tell us about her parents. And she would name them and she would talk about these different names. And so we wrote all these names down that she would say and tried to spell them the best we knew how. Well, come to find out these were her siblings and her parents that were sleeping together on the floor of the fale. Fale is a word for house.
她开始跟我们讲起她的父母。她会叫出他们的名字，说出不同的名字。于是我们把她说的所有名字都记下来，尽我们所能拼写出来。结果发现，这些是她睡在“法勒”（Fale）地板上的兄弟姐妹和父母。法勒是房子的意思。
So immediately, when she starts talking about sleeping with her family on the floor in the fale, we had the question come up, well, why would a little girl who was supposed to have been in foster care in the nanny house for almost nine months prior to us adopting her-- that put her just barely over three years old-- why would she be still talking about her parents? Why wouldn't she be referring to the nanny and the nanny's husband?
所以当她开始说和家人睡在地板上时，我们马上就产生了一个疑问：为什么一个应该在领养前几乎一直在保姆房待了九个月的小女孩——那让她刚三岁多一点——为什么还会一直提到她的父母？为什么她不是提到保姆和保姆的丈夫？
There were other clues that something wasn't right. They dug up a photo the adoption agency had sent, supposedly taken of Elleia at the nanny house, and discovered it didn't match the photos of the nanny house that were on the internet. Mike and Kari were realizing they'd been lied to in little ways, and they wondered if they were being lied to in big ways. So they started digging around. A friend's brother-in-law was working with the LDS church in Samoa and agreed to help them. He got a translator and tried to track down Elleia's birth parents-- the [? Soes ?] in the remote jungle village listed on Elleia's birth certificate.
还有其他线索表明情况不对。他们找出了领养机构寄来的那张所谓的艾莉娅在保姆房拍摄的照片，发现它与网上保姆房的照片不匹配。迈克和卡莉意识到他们在小事上被骗了，他们想知道在大事上是否也被骗了。于是他们开始四处打听。一位朋友的姐夫在萨摩亚为LDS教会工作，同意帮助他们。他找了一位翻译，试图找到艾莉娅的亲生父母——在艾莉娅出生证明上列出的那个偏远丛林村庄里的“索伊”（Soe）一家。
They headed out past where maps could take them and eventually found some of Elleia's relatives. Not Tupu, her mother, but Ama, Elleia's oldest sister, and her husband Tovea who spoke English. [? Tovea explained that the girl had always lived with them, not in the nanny house, and that the [? Soe ?] family had a very different understanding of what they had signed their girl up for. It was this.
他们朝着地图以外的地方出发，最终找到了艾莉娅的一些亲戚。不是图普，她的母亲，而是阿玛，艾莉娅的大姐，以及她的丈夫托维亚，他会说英语。托维亚解释说女孩一直和他们住在一起，而不是在保姆房里，而且索伊一家对他们把女孩送出去的意义有完全不同的理解。是这样的。
Elleia was going to be here in the United States until she was 18 years old. She would be getting an American education and that we, the American family, were supposed to be sending money to the birth family during that time span while she's here in the United States. Then when she turned 18, of course, she would return to Samoa with that education and be able to support the family or whatever they saw fit.
艾莉娅将要在美国待到18岁。她会接受美国教育，而我们，美国这边的家庭，要在她在美国的这段时间里给亲生家庭寄钱。然后当她满18岁时，她当然会带着教育回到萨摩亚，有能力供养家庭或做他们认为合适的任何事情。
The [? Soes ?] seemed to believe this was a study abroad program and that they'd be receiving updates, photos, letters, and gifts. Of course, this was not at all what the adoption agency had told Mike and Kari, which is that this girl was left it a nanny house nine months earlier by a family they couldn't afford to feed her, and that it was a traditional closed adoption, where the birth family would have no claim to their child. The [? Soes, ?] it turned out, were farmers with plenty to eat and more to sell at market.
索伊一家似乎相信这是一个留学项目，他们会收到后续信息、照片、信件和礼物。当然，这与领养机构告诉迈克和卡莉的完全不同，机构说这女孩九个月前因为家庭无法负担她的食物而被扔在保姆房里，而且这是一种传统的封闭式领养，亲生家庭对孩子没有任何要求。结果证明，索伊一家是农民，有充足的食物，还能卖给市场更多。
And worst of all was the story of the [? Soes ?] last interaction with their daughter. Someone from the adoption agency came by one evening to get the girl and told the [? Soes ?] that she was just spending a night in the nanny house to get used to being away from home. The man told them Elleia would be back the next day. Instead, that same night she was taken straight to the airport and put on a flight to New Zealand.
最糟糕的是关于索伊一家最后一次与女儿见面的故事。领养机构的人某天晚上来带走女孩，告诉索伊一家她只是在保姆房住一晚以习惯离开家的生活。那个人告诉他们艾莉娅第二天就会回来。相反，就在当天晚上，她被直接带到机场，被送上了去新西兰的飞机。
So we were getting this little girl, unbeknownst to us, that had been with her parents two hours earlier, not knowing that they were fully planning on seeing her the next day, but never to see her again. And once they figured out she wasn't coming back, imagine how terrified they were.
所以我们接到的这个小女孩，在不知情的情况下，两个小时前还和父母在一起，当时他们完全计划好第二天见到她，却再也没见过。而当他们发现她不会回来时，想象一下他们有多恐惧。
To understand why the [? Soes ?] would even agree in the first place to a deal like the one they described, it helps to know that in Samoa, there is no tradition of relinquishing your legal rights to a child. There are no orphanages there. There is no such thing as adoption. Samoans generally have large families, and it's not unusual to send a child for a time to other family members or friends who can better afford to raise him or her. To them, it just becomes an extended family. So to the [? Soes, ?] the idea of sending a child off to be taken care of and educated in the US didn't seem all that odd.
为了理解为什么索伊一家最初会同意他们描述的那种协议，了解一点有助于理解：在萨摩亚，没有放弃孩子合法权利的传统。那里没有孤儿院。没有“领养”这回事。萨摩亚人通常有大家庭，把孩子送去给能供养得更好的亲戚或朋友待一段时间并不罕见。对他们来说，这只是变成了大家庭。所以对索伊一家来说，把孩子送走去美国接受照顾和教育，看起来并不奇怪。
After hearing all of this from their man in Samoa, the Nybergs took a huge step. They went to the authorities. They told what they'd found to the State Department agent, who had processed their application to adopt, and to an agent from immigration and customs. Both agents were shocked. Mike and Kari knew that the case would escalate, but they had no idea what would happen to their family. They'd had Elleia for almost six months.
在从他们萨摩亚的人那里听到这一切后，奈伯格夫妇采取了一个重大步骤。他们报警了。他们把发现的情况告诉了国务院代理人，也就是处理他们领养申请的那个人，以及移民和海关的一名代理人。两位代理人都震惊了。迈克和卡莉知道案件会升级，但他们不知道这对他们的家庭意味着什么。他们养艾莉娅已经快六个月了。
Did you think about whether you would have to give her back at that stage?
那个阶段你有没有想过是否必须把她还回去？
Oh yeah. Yeah, absolutely. I thought, well, if this adoption isn't supposed to be, then is this child really ours? Whose family does she belong to? It was scary.
噢，有的。有的，绝对想过。我想，好吧，如果这领养不该发生，那么这孩子真的是我们的吗？她属于哪个家庭？太可怕了。
What did this do to your relationship with Elleia herself? How do you react to that?
这事儿对你和艾莉娅本人的关系有什么影响？你对此有何反应？
Well, I didn't allow it to-- and not that I was consciously making a choice-- I continued to bond with her. I treated her normally. I think my wife kind of went the other direction. She probably had some concerns and so I think she kind of became standoffish. Knowing that maybe this adoption is fraudulent and we won't get to keep this little girl, how can I let myself get attached to her?
嗯，我没让它——不是说我在自觉地做选择——我继续与她建立了联系。我正常对待她。我想我妻子可能走向了另一个方向。她可能有一些担忧，所以我想她变得有点冷淡。知道也许这次领养是欺诈，我们无法留下这个小女孩，我怎么能让自己对她产生感情呢？
Kari didn't want to speak to us for this story. She did send me an email answering some of my questions but didn't address this particular point. So we only have Mike's perspective on this.
卡莉不想在这个故事中接受采访。她确实发了一封电子邮件回答我的一些问题，但没有谈到这一点。所以我们只有迈克对此的看法。
The government started its investigation, interviewing dozens of families in America and in Samoa. And for a long time, there was nothing Mike and Kari could do except wait. Finally, they decided to fly to Samoa themselves with Elleia to meet her family, the [? Soes. ?] At this point, Mike and Kari had been raising Elleia as their daughter for almost two years. The two families arranged to meet at an LDS temple in Apia, the capital. Elleia recognized her parents immediately and they picked her up and hugged her and cried.
政府开始了调查，采访了美国和萨摩亚的数十个家庭。很长一段时间里，迈克和卡莉除了等待别无他法。最终，他们决定亲自带着艾莉娅飞往萨摩亚去见她的家人，即索伊一家。此时，迈克和卡莉作为女儿抚养艾莉娅已经快两年了。两家人安排在阿皮亚（首都）的一座LDS圣殿见面。艾莉娅立刻认出了她的父母，他们抱起她，拥抱她，哭了起来。
You're all standing there meeting for the first time. And it's immediate, it's apparent that this is their girl and she wants to be with them?
你们都在那里第一次见面。立刻就很明显这是他们的女孩，而她想和他们在一起吗？
No, not necessarily. It's a very strange situation because she was hesitant going to them because she'd been away from them for a while. She really didn't want to stay with them. Right after that, we loaded up into a vehicle and headed to their village and spent time out there. It took her time to readjust back into her family. They very much loved their daughter. You could absolutely tell. But she was really bonded to me and when I was there, she didn't seem to want anything to do with anybody else-- wanted to sit on daddy's lap.
不，不一定。这是一个非常奇怪的情况，因为她离开他们一段时间，所以对走向他们有点犹豫。她真的不想留在那儿。就在那之后，我们装上车前往他们的村庄，在那里待了一段时间。她花了点时间重新适应她的家庭。他们非常爱他们的女儿。你绝对看得出来。但她真的跟我很亲，我在那儿的时候，她似乎不想跟任何人扯上关系——只想坐在爸爸的膝盖上。
And seeing where she was from, you come around a corner and you see this building with palm leaves on the roof and no outside walls, just poles holding the roof up. And then to start looking around and see how dirty it is, how filthy the kids' clothes were that lived there, just living amidst all the mud and dirt and lava rock, and we all sit on the floor. Everybody pretty much sits in a big circle. The kids kind of run around. That have one little light bulb-- about a sixty-watt light bulb in the ceiling there, and that's their light.
看到她来自哪里，你拐个弯，看到这栋房顶铺着棕榈叶、没有外墙、只有杆子支撑屋顶的建筑。然后开始环顾四周，看到这里有多脏，住在那里的小孩衣服有多脏，就住在泥土、灰尘和熔岩之中，我们所有人坐在地板上。每个人基本都坐在一个大圈子里。孩子们跑来跑去。那里只有一个灯泡——天花板上一个大约60瓦的灯泡，那是他们的光。
It was hard to communicate. More than just a language barrier, there was a cultural barrier. It wasn't clear what to talk about. Mike says they didn't seem to want to discuss what had happened or why it happened. All they really wanted to know was what would happen next.
交流很难。不仅仅是语言障碍，还有文化障碍。不清楚该谈论什么。迈克说他们似乎不想讨论发生了什么或为什么会发生。他们真正想知道的只是接下来会发生什么。
Initially, that's the first thing they ask is, OK, what's the program? And that was their way of asking us, why are you here? What are we doing? Is Elleia coming back to live with us or is she going back home with you? They know that we love her and they know that we are taking care of her and they can see that she's in good hands and they appreciate that and they want us to make the decision. It wasn't up to them, it was up to us to decide what to do.
最初，他们问的第一件事就是：“好的，计划是什么？”这是他们询问我们的一种方式，问为什么要来？我们在做什么？艾莉娅是要回来跟我们住，还是跟你回去了？他们知道我们爱她，他们知道我们照顾她，他们看得出她被照顾得很好，他们对此很感激，他们想让我们做决定。这不取决于他们，取决于我们决定做什么。
It was dark when Mike and Kari left the village to drive back to their hotel. In the car, they struggled to figure out what would be best.
迈克和卡莉离开村庄开车回酒店时天已经黑了。在车里，他们挣扎着思考什么才是最好的。
We're talking about a human life-- a little girl-- and to treat it like it's a box of bananas it seemed unreasonable and unfathomable to me because now I have to decide what to do with her and I love her to death. She was just like my own flesh and blood. But it also gave me a taste of how her own parents really felt not having her and not being able to be with her. I think I felt the same love they felt for their daughter.
我们在谈论一条生命——一个小女孩——把它当作一箱香蕉来对待，对我来说似乎是不合理和不可思议的，因为现在我必须决定怎么对待她，而我爱她爱得要命。她就像我自己的骨肉。但也让我体会到她亲生父母因为没有她、不能和她在一起是什么感觉。我想我感受到了他们对女儿的同样的爱。
When I asked Kari about this in an email, she said she also felt for Elleia's parents. She'd lost a child-- a two- month old-- and she said knowing there was another mother out there who lost her child broker her heart. "There was no way I would put another mother through that pain," she wrote. Mike and Kari decided to leave Elleia with her birth family. It's a decision Mike describes as the right one, but he still plays it over and over in his mind. His biggest consideration, he says, was his wife's relationship with Elleia.
当我在邮件里问卡莉时，她说她也同情艾莉娅的父母。她曾失去过一个两个月大的孩子，她说知道外面有另一个母亲失去了孩子让她心碎。“我绝不会让另一个母亲经历那种痛苦，”她写道。迈克和卡莉决定把艾莉娅留给亲生家庭。迈克描述这是一个正确的决定，但他仍在脑海里反复重播。他说他最大的考虑是他妻子与艾莉娅的关系。
Let's put it this way, Ted. If it was just me that had made that choice, there's a lot higher possibility that she wouldn't have stayed there. Maybe because I'm selfish. I don't know. Maybe it's a little strong to say that I would definitely have not left her there, but I think I wanted Elleia a little bit more than what my wife did. The fact that she hadn't bonded with Elleia, it wasn't as difficult for her to make that choice. But as a couple, you decide what would be best for the entire situation.
这样说吧，泰德。如果只是我做那个选择，她留在那儿的可能性要高得多。也许因为我自私。我不知道。也许说我肯定不会把她留在那儿有点太武断，但我认为我比我妻子更想要艾莉娅。事实是她没和艾莉娅建立那种联系，对她来说做那个选择没那么困难。但作为夫妻，你们要决定什么对整个局面最好。
In the end, Mike took comfort in the only thing that seemed like solid footing-- the idea that he could remedy an injustice by returning Elleia.
最后，迈克从唯一看起来像坚实基础的事情中得到了安慰——他可以靠送回艾莉娅来弥补不公的想法。
The middle ground that I kept standing on was that she was given to us on false pretenses. And we were lied to. They were lied to. Maybe she just isn't supposed to be with us.
我一直站着的中立立场是，她是基于虚假借口给我们的。我们被骗了。他们也被骗了。也许她注定就不该跟我们在一起。
Did you worry that Elleia would suffer? Did you feel like you were abandoning her in any way?
你担心艾莉娅会受苦吗？你有没有觉得自己在某种程度上抛弃了她？
I absolutely did. The night that we left, we were getting ready to go to the airport, standing in the village, and I could not peel her off of me. She was crying and we were talking to her, trying to let her know that it would all be OK and that she was going to be able to stay with Tupu and Isea. And she just bawled and bawled. And she clung to my neck and would not let go. And her mom tried to take her. And her mom couldn't get her off of me. Her dad couldn't get her off of me. And finally her brother, he was able to peel her off my neck. We found out that she cried herself to sleep for several weeks after that.
我绝对担心。我们离开的那天晚上，准备去机场，站在村子里，我无法把她从我身上揭下来。她在哭，我们在跟她说话，试图让她知道一切都会好起来，她可以和图普及伊塞亚待在一起。她只是不停地哭啊哭。她紧紧抓着我的脖子不肯放手。她的母亲试图带走她，但她母亲拽不开。她父亲拽不开。最后她的哥哥，他成功把她从我脖子上拽了下来。我们发现她在之后几周哭着睡着了。
Mike and Kari returned to Utah alone. Mike says the house was strange without her. They kept her room the same-- her girly bed, some clothes that no longer fit. Her little bike was still in the garage. Every couple of weeks, they would call Samoa just to check in.
迈克和卡莉独自回到了犹他州。迈克说没有她的屋子感觉很奇怪。他们保持她的房间原样——她的女孩床，一些不再合适的衣服。她的小自行车还在车库里。每隔几周，他们会打给萨摩亚问候一下。
And that went on for, oh gosh, it'd been about five, six months. And they had the ability to call us from their cell phones also. And they called us one day and they said, "we know that you love Elleia, and if you would like to have her back, you can have her."
这种情况持续了，噢天哪，大约五六个月。他们也可以用手机打给我们。有一天他们打来说：“我们知道你们爱艾莉娅，如果你们想接她回来，可以接回来。”
For weeks, I called the [? Soes ?] to hear their side of this, but it always went straight to voicemail. The one time I did get through, I spoke with Elleia's sister-in-law, who said they didn't have any minutes on the phone card and couldn't talk. If it seems hard to believe that they'd give Elleia back again, Mike says it's really pretty straightforward. He believes the [? Soes ?] had come to trust him and Kari and now thought of them as extended family. And her parents knew, if they sent Elleia back, she'd have all the advantages they wanted for her in America, and they'd still get to see her and be part of her life.
几周来，我一直联系索伊一家想听他们的说法，但总是直接进语音信箱。唯一一次接通时，我与艾莉娅的嫂子交谈，她说电话卡没钱了，说不了话。如果觉得他们又送回艾莉娅很难相信，迈克说这其实很简单。他相信索伊一家已经学会信任他和卡莉，现在把他们当成了大家庭的一员。而且她的父母知道，如果他们把艾莉娅送回去，她会得到他们希望她在美国家得到的一切优势，而且他们依然能见到她，并成为她生活的一部分。
They could feel it. They knew that she was in a good situation, probably the situation that they had dreamed for her. Honestly, for me, I felt joy. I thought, really? OK. Well, that's neat.
他们能感觉到。他们知道她在好的境况里，可能就是他们为她梦想的境况。老实说，我感受到了快乐。我想，真的吗？好的。哇，真好。
Did you think that Elleia had been unhappy there and wanted to come back or would benefit from coming back?
你认为艾莉娅在那里不快乐，想回来或回来会受益吗？
Well, I knew that she had been unhappy in the initial month because of hearing about how she cried herself to sleep every night. And, of course, I was very concerned about that-- very concerned that maybe having gone through as much as she's gone through, it was detrimental to her mental and spiritual well-being. And now I can kind of keep an eye on her and I can make sure she's provided for and I don't have to wonder how she's doing.
嗯，我知道她最初一个月是不快乐的，因为听说她每天晚上怎么哭着睡着。当然，我非常担心——非常担心也许经历了这么多，这对她的心理和精神健康是有害的。现在我能盯着她，能确保她得到照顾，我不用再纳闷她过得怎么样了。
They went back to Samoa to pick up a Elleia.
他们回到了萨摩亚去接艾莉娅。
That week in Samoa was a wonderful reunion for everybody. We made sure that most of her family was able to go to the airport to see her off. And when we went to get on the airplane, some of her family were in tears but she wasn't in tears and she wasn't fighting to stay with them. I think more Elleia is resolved to, oh, well, this is just the way life is. This is what I do. I go back and forth.
萨摩亚的那一周对每个人来说都是美妙的重聚。我们确保她的大多数家人都能去机场送行。当我们去登机时，她的一些家人在流泪，但她没有流泪，也没有挣扎着要留下来。我想更多是艾莉娅的决定，哦，好吧，这就是生活的方式。这就是我做的。我来来回回。
Back in Utah, Elleia was soon at home again, sleeping in her old room, playing with her two brothers. She started up school in the fall. And mike said he was so hopeful about the whole thing that his wife would come to feel as close to Elleia as he did. But things didn't really improve.
回到犹他州，艾莉娅很快又在家里安顿下来，睡在她旧房间里，和两个哥哥玩耍。她秋天开始上学。迈克说他对此充满希望，希望妻子能像他一样和艾莉娅亲近。但情况并没有真正好转。
In June was when she came back. In October, my wife asked me for a divorce.
六月她回来的。十月，我妻子向我提出了离婚。
The past three and a half years had been rough on Mike and Kari's marriage. The stress of adopting and then giving Elleia back was huge in itself, but on top of that was the investigation into the adoption agency, Focus on Children. The Nybergs were in constant contact with various law enforcement agencies. The case had sort of taken over their lives. It was exhausting. The day after they decided to split up, Mike called the [? Soes ?] to let them know. Now he was asking them what they wanted to do-- leave Elleia with him or take her back.
过去的三年半对迈克和卡莉的婚姻很艰难。领养然后送回艾莉娅的压力本身就很大，此外还有对领养机构“关注孩子”的调查。奈伯格夫妇与各种执法机构保持着持续联系。这个案子几乎占用了他们的全部生活。这太让人筋疲力尽了。他们决定分手后的第二天，迈克打给索伊一家告知情况。现在他在问他们想做什么——把艾莉娅留给他，还是接回去。
Well, I knew full well that their idea for their daughter was to be here with an LDS family in the United States, but the key word there is family, and an operative family where there's a mother and a father, not a divorce situation. So I called them the next day, the [? Soes, ?] and presented to them what was happening and asked them what they would like to do. And they chose to have Elleia come back to Samoa. And when they did, they said, if you and Kari ever get back together again, you can have Elleia again.
好吧，我很清楚他们对女儿的设想是待在美国的LDS家庭里，但关键在于“家庭”这个词，是一个有母亲和父亲的正常家庭，而不是离婚的境况。所以我第二天打给了索伊一家，陈述了正在发生的事情，并问他们想怎么做。他们选择了让艾莉娅回到萨摩亚。当他们这样做时，他们说，如果你和卡莉哪天复合，你还可以再要回艾莉娅。
What did you tell her-- Elleia?
你跟她——艾莉娅说了什么？
Just told her that she was going to go back to live with her family in Samoa. And at that age, you can't really tell her a whole lot. We certainly didn't tell her we were getting divorced. And I'm not sure that Elleia knows why she was going back and forth.
只是告诉她她要回萨摩亚和家人住了。在那个年纪，你不能告诉她太多。我们当然没告诉她我们要离婚了。我不确定艾莉娅是否知道她为什么来来回回。
So we got to the airport and put her on an Air New Zealand flight that goes straight to Apia, Samoa. Wow. I'll never forget that day. And I really didn't feel comfortable with it. They called her name-- they usually let the children on first-- and they came to get her, and so we walked her right to the ramp. And she held the lady's hand and walked down the ramp and got on the plane and that's the last we saw of her at that point.
所以我们到了机场，把她送上了直飞萨摩亚阿皮亚的纽西兰航空班机。哇。那一天我永远忘不了。我真的觉得不舒服。他们叫了她的名字——通常先让孩子们上——他们来接她，所以我们直接把她送到了登机桥。她拉着那位女士的手，走了下去，上了飞机，那就是我们在那个时刻最后一次见到她。
Mike still wonders about all of this-- every step. And when he does, he comes back to this weird balance where he believes he did the right thing, but he can't exactly explain why it was right, even to himself.
迈克依然在想这一切——每一步。当他这样做时，他回到了那种奇怪的平衡中，他相信自己做了正确的事，但他无法解释为什么是对的，甚至对自己也无法解释。
I know a lot of this probably is hard to understand. Every decision I made in this process was through prayer and I can't explain to you why I received the answers that I did, but I can tell you that now, sometimes the answers don't seem reasonable or they just don't make sense.
我知道这其中很多可能很难理解。我在这个过程中做的每个决定都是通过祷告做出的，我无法解释我为什么收到那样的答案，但我可以告诉你，现在，有时这些答案似乎并不合理，或者根本说不通。
After more than three years of remarkable efforts, I am pleased to be here to discuss what I refer to as the thoughtful resolution of the most difficult and unique case that we've seen in this office in a long time. In resolving this case with guilty pleas--
经过三年多的卓越努力，我很高兴能在这里讨论我所说的对我们办公室长期以来看到的最困难和独特的案件的深思熟虑的解决。通过认罪协议解决此案——
On February 25th, Brett Tolman, the US Attorney for Utah, spoke to the press about the sentencing of the owners and staff of the adoption agency Focus on Children. Two years earlier, he had filed his indictment-- 135 counts involving 37 families. But in the end, owner Scott and Karen Banks pled guilty to much reduced charges. They admitted to some false statements made in the adoption paperwork but not a lot more. They didn't admit to intentional deception or fraud. The judge required them to pay into a fund for counseling for some of the children and to help the US and Samoan families keep in touch, although the court isn't forcing the US families to initiate contact. Most important, the judge banned Scott and Karen Banks and all their employees from the adoption business for life.
2月25日，美国犹他州检察官布雷特·托尔曼向媒体谈到了对领养机构“关注孩子”的所有者和员工的量刑。两年前，他提起了指控——涉及37个家庭的135项罪名。但最终，所有者斯科特和卡伦·班克斯对大幅减轻的指控认罪。他们承认领养文书中有一些虚假陈述，但没承认更多。他们没有承认蓄意欺骗或欺诈。法官要求他们支付一笔资金，用于部分孩子的咨询，并帮助美国和萨摩亚家庭保持联系，尽管法院并没强制美国家庭发起联系。最重要的是，法官终身禁止斯科特和卡伦·班克斯及其所有员工从事领养业务。
International adoption fraud cases like this have almost never made it into US courts. There's only been one other instance so far. So adoption advocates all over the country were watching closely. And when they heard the plea deal-- no jail time, not even probation-- they were outraged. Tolman knew this and wearily explained why the case ended as it did. He clearly had struggled-- just like Mike Nyberg-- to make sense of the whole thing.
像这样的国际领养欺诈案几乎从未进入过美国法庭。到目前为止只有一例。所以全国各地的领养倡导者都在密切关注。当他们听说认罪协议时——没有入狱时间，甚至没有缓刑——他们愤怒了。托尔曼知道这一点，疲惫地解释了为什么案件会这样结束。他显然挣扎过——就像迈克·奈伯格一样——试图搞懂这一切。
We do not pretend-- I do not pretend to have the perfect answer or the perfect approach. At the heart of this case has always been the children. When the choice became the welfare, future, and lives of the children versus the amount of jail time and sheer punishment of the defendants, I chose the children and avoiding further innocents from suffering.
我们并不假装——我不假装有完美的答案或完美的方案。此案的核心始终是孩子们。当选择成为孩子的福利、未来和生活与被告的刑期和纯粹的惩罚时，我选择了孩子们，避免了更多无辜者受苦。
What that meant in practice was that Tolman and his team didn't want to drag the adoptive families through a trial, which many of the families feared could attract too much attention from the Samoan government or immigration and customs-- anyone who might question their right to keep their adopted children. There could still be civil suits. A custody fight. At least one Samoan father is actively trying to get his child back, but that's unusual.
在实践中这意味着，托尔曼和他的团队不想把被领养的家庭拖入一场审判，许多家庭担心这会吸引萨摩亚政府或移民和海关的太多注意——任何可能质疑他们留下被领养孩子的权利的人。可能还会有民事诉讼。监护权争夺战。至少有一位萨摩亚父亲正在积极试图要回他的孩子，但这并不常见。
Prosecutors say that most of the Samoan families are not seeking their children's return. In interviews, they told investigators they just wanted to make sure their kids were safe. They wanted to do what's best for them. And none of the other American families involved wanted to do what the Nybergs did-- return their children to Samoa.
检察官说，大多数萨摩亚家庭并不寻求要回孩子。在采访中，他们告诉调查员，他们只是想确保孩子们是安全的。他们想为孩子做最好的。而其他涉及的美国家庭中，没有一个想做奈伯格夫妇做的那样——把孩子送回萨摩亚。
As the prosecution team realized this, the meaning of justice in this case changed. Jonathan Lines handled the case for immigration and customs. He said a couple of his investigators were unusually disturbed by what they learned. As parents, they couldn't quite draw enough distance. And by now, neither Lines nor anyone else is prepared to argue that the kids should be returned to Samoa.
当检控团队意识到这一点时，此案中正义的含义发生了变化。乔纳森·莱恩斯处理了移民和海关的案件。他说他的两名调查员对所学到的东西感到异常不安。作为父母，他们无法保持足够的距离。而现在，莱恩斯和其他人都不准备争论说孩子们应该送回萨摩亚。
The only perspective I can give you is from my own human perspective. I don't know that I could give a child back. This is an absolute conundrum and it's something that I don't know will be easily resolved. That's why the investigation and a resolution that would seek real and true justice, I don't know that that's ever possible in a scenario like this.
我能给出的唯一观点是我自己的人类视角。我不知道能不能送回一个孩子。这绝对是个难题，我不确定能轻易解决。这就是为什么调查和寻求真正正义的解决方案，我不确定在这样的场景下是否可能。
As for the other families in this case, most of them say they wish Mike had never gone to the feds at all, that there'd never been an indictment. They've been angry with Mike and they thought he was crazy to give back his daughter.
至于此案中的其他家庭，他们大多数人说希望迈克当初根本不要找联邦政府，希望从来没有过起诉。他们对迈克感到愤怒，认为送回女儿简直疯了。
Rod Young was one of three parents who spoke at the sentencing. He testified in defense of Focus on Children, who brought him his son, [? Tawni. ?] Rod loves [? Tawni ?] so much he gets choked up just talking about him. And he makes the same argument the Bankses themselves made in their own defense. They did so much good in adoptions worldwide. They brought so much aid to poor communities. Plus, these kids are better off here. And if the Bankses cut a few corners in their business, that's only a tiny part of the whole picture. I spoke to Rod Young right after the sentencing.
罗德·杨是量刑时发言的三位父母之一。他为带给他儿子“托尼”的“关注孩子”机构进行辩护。罗德是如此爱托尼，提到他就哽咽。他提出了班克斯夫妇自己辩护时提出的相同论点。他们在全球领养中做了那么多好事。他们为贫困社区带来了那么多援助。此外，这些孩子在这里更好。如果班克斯夫妇在经营中抄了近路，那也只是全局的一小部分。我是在量刑后立刻与罗德·杨交谈的。
I don't know if you heard, but they've done over a thousand adoptions. And today's event was focused on 39 of them, of which we only heard from two that were really, really angry and I believe that those were the ones that started the whole thing. There was nothing wrong with our adoption.
我不知道你们听没听说，他们做了超过一千次领养。今天的活动重点关注了其中的39个，其中我们只听到了两个真的非常非常愤怒的人，我相信就是那两个引发了整个事情。我们的领养没有任何问题。
Do you feel that this case puts your family at risk?
你觉得这个案件让你的家庭处于危险中了吗？
Potentially. That's the biggest fear. And hopefully, today, what I was able to do a little bit and what I said was in speaking out was to say, hey look, these children are here. They're already so much more advantaged by a thousand percent from where they come from. And we love the Samoan culture, but if I had a nickel for every person that touched my son and said lucky baby, just to reach out and touch him as we were going through the markets-- the people that would take him and hold him and say lucky baby, lucky baby, and then give him back to us because they know what he was coming back to as opposed to what was there. It's a wonderful life, but there's nothing there for the children.
潜在地。那是最大的恐惧。希望今天，我能够做到的和我说的是在说出来，看，这些孩子们在这里。比起他们来的地方，他们已经优越了百分之一千。我们爱萨摩亚文化，但如果我的儿子被每个人碰到，人们都说“幸运的宝贝”，在我穿过市场时人们伸出手去碰他——那些抱起他并说“幸运的宝贝，幸运的宝贝”，然后把他还给我们的人，因为他们知道比起那里的情况，他将要来到什么样的地方。这是一个美好的生活，但那里对孩子们来说什么都没有。
Mike Nyberg can understand why other parents haven't done what he did. He gets that his extraordinary decision might never be repeated by other families.
迈克·奈伯格能理解为什么其他父母没做他做的那样。他明白他非凡的决定可能永远不会被其他家庭重复。
Why don't they want to give the children back if you did and you knew it was the right thing? Are all these people not doing the right thing?
既然你做了并且知道是正确的，为什么他们不想把孩子送回去？难道所有这些人都没有做正确的事吗？
I can't speak for them. I know how I feel about Elleia and I know how difficult it is and I wouldn't wish that on my worst enemy. It is a decision that nobody should ever have to make. So these are questions that nobody's ever had to answer before. And there are no answers to those questions of what's right and what's wrong. Because if they send all the kids back to Samoa, you're doing essentially the same thing happened to those children to begin with-- ripping them out of their homes. But do they really belong to these families? That's God's call. But you know what? I don't think he's going to tell us. I think we just have to make the right choice.
我无法替他们说话。我知道我对艾莉娅的感受，我知道这有多难，我绝不会把它强加给我最大的敌人。这是没人应该面对的决定。所以这是以前没人需要回答的问题。关于什么是对、什么是错，这些问题没有答案。因为如果他们把所有孩子送回萨摩亚，你本质上是在做和起初对那些孩子做的一样的事——把他们从家里撕走。但他们真的属于这些家庭吗？那是上帝的旨意。但你知道吗？我不认为他会告诉我们。我想我们只需要做出正确的选择。
Since February 2007, when Mike and Kari said goodbye to Elleia at the airport, Mike has gone back to Samoa once for a visit. He brought his two sons so they could really see where she was. Mike said they never understood it before just looking at the globe, at a tiny dot in the middle of the Pacific Ocean. Mike's dream is to one day have enough money to bring Elleia over here for extended visits every year or two. And in Samoa, not too long after Elleia's return, one of her older sisters had a baby boy. She named him Mike. A few months after that, another sister gave birth to another boy. They named this one Nyberg.
自2007年2月迈克和卡莉在机场告别艾莉娅以来，迈克回过一次萨摩亚。他带了两个儿子，这样他们能真正看到她在那儿。迈克说他们以前从没理解过，只看地球仪上太平洋中间的一个小点。迈克的梦想是一天有足够的钱能每年或每两年带艾莉娅过来作长时间访问。而在萨摩亚，艾莉娅回来不久后，她的一个大姐生了个小男孩。她给他取名迈克。几个月后，另一个姐姐生了另一个男孩。他们给这个取名奈伯格。
Ted Gesing is a TV documentary producer.
泰德·格辛是一位电视纪录片制作人。
A chimpanzee can tear a man apart with his bare hands.
黑猩猩徒手就能把人撕碎。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多“这个美国生活”的故事回来。